- You know, I think
the big syndrome,
among most Democrats,
if you wanna give them the
benefit of the doubt is
that they are big
heart, small brain.
And so, they think
with their heart
and they just wanna help people,
don't you just
wanna help people?
But they don't think through
the consequences of this.
it's sort of like unemployment.
We just wanna help people.
So why don't we double
the unemployment?
But what it does is it
leads to people staying out
of work longer.
And in the end,
when they decide to go
back in the workforce,
people are like, well,
you've only been out
of work 10 weeks,
but you've been out
of work a whole year
because the benefits were good.
You know what, I'd rather have
the guy who's only been out
of work 10 weeks.
He seems hungrier to me.
And so, you create
a whole class,
an underclass of people
who are unemployable
and no longer part
of the workforce.
And that wasn't good for them.
Work is good for the soul,
good for the heart,
I mean, it's good
for the person.
And once you get them
out of the workforce,
you've done a disservice
to that, to them.
And you make them, sort of,
a dependent on the
democratic largesse
and then they become
a solid Democrat voter
because they no longer
work or pay taxes.
(calm music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today is
one of the last sane men
in Washington, DC, as well as
Dr. Fauchi's worst nightmare,
Senator Rand Paul, welcome
back to The Rubin Report.
- Glad to be with you, Dave.
- Senator, I have a
short list here of people
that are sane in Washington, DC,
you're at the top of the list.
And then I put Abraham
Lincoln, George Washington,
and Ted Cruz.
- You know, two of
- You got any,
any other company
- two of those three,
- in that town?
- Two of those three are
no longer here, Dave.
I mean, I know this
isn't a newsflash.
(Dave laughing)
but Lincoln and
Washington, no longer here,
but it is a small,
- I felt I had to pad the
list a little, you know?
- It's a small group.
- Yeah, I mean, how
does that make you feel
on a day-to-day basis,
dealing with some
of the nonsense
that we're gonna spend
these 20 minutes talking
about that it seems that
everything that a good,
decent libertarian has
warned about for a long time
just seems to be
ushering in every second.
We wake up and another
infringement on this
or that is here.
- Do you know what?
I think politicians
would be surprised.
I go home and
people come up to me
and they thank me for
standing up to these people.
And I think that a lot of
people think if they stand up,
they'll get in trouble
with their constituents.
I think it's the opposite.
People at home are proud of
the fact that I'll stand up
when nobody else will.
And that I'm saying things
that they're thinking at home,
but nobody in Washington
seems to be defending them on.
And it's amazing how many
people are speaking out.
One of the things I've
been impressed with is,
I don't know a lot
of NBA players,
but I talked to Jonathan
Isaac the other day.
- [Dave] Uh-huh.
- I've seen his video,
his interview,
smart young man, makes
a measured response,
says that he wants to make
his own medical decisions,
as I do, you know,
having had the disease
based on the literature,
based on the scientific data.
I've even said,
I might get vaccinated some day,
if the data looks like it
indicates that I need to be.
But the thing is, is we
have millions of Americans
and nobody's representing
them up here.
They're sort of like
just blindly follow,
blindly do as your told, and
that's not the American way.
The American way is actually
to question authority,
to debate, to kibitz,
to do you, you know,
whatever it is to try
to get at the truth.
But we figure out the
truth individually,
not as a collective.
- Yeah, I shared a clip this
morning of astrophysicist,
Carl Sagan, who's long gone,
but he was talking
about how healthy
skepticism is the one thing
that guards us from
authoritarianism.
And if you were to say
that now, you know,
you're basically
considered far right.
But with everything
you said in mind,
you had a rather extraordinary
exchange with Health
and Homeland Secretary,
Xavier Bassera.
So we're gonna throw to
about a minute of that.
- Mr. Bassera, are you
familiar with an Israeli study
that had 2.5 million patients
and found that the vaccinated
group was actually seven times
more likely to get infected
with COVID than the people
that had gotten COVID naturally?
- Senator, I'd have to get
back to you on that one.
I'm not familiar
with that study.
- Well, you think
you might want to be,
if you're gonna travel the
country insulting the millions
of Americans, including
NBA star, Jonathan Isaac,
who have had COVID, recovered,
look at a study with 2.5
million people and say, well,
you know what, it looks
like my immunity's
as good as the vaccine or not
and in a free country,
maybe I ought to be able
to make that decision.
Instead, you've chosen
to travel the country,
calling people like
Jonathan Isaac and others,
myself included, flat earthers.
We find that very insulting.
It goes against the science.
Are you a doctor,
a medical doctor?
- I have worked over 30
years on health policy.
- So you're not
a medical doctor?
Do you have a science degree?
And yet, you travel the country
calling people flat earthers
who have had COVID, looked at
studies of millions of people,
and made their own
personal decision
that their immunity
they naturally
acquired is sufficient.
But you presume somehow to tell
over a hundred million
Americans, who survived COVID,
that we have no right to
determine our own medical care.
You, alone, are on high, and
you've made these decisions,
a lawyer with no scientific
background, no medical degree.
This is an arrogance coupled
with an authoritarianism
that is unseemly
and un-American.
You, sir, are the one
ignoring the science.
The vast preponderance
of scientific studies,
dozens and dozens show
robust, long-lasting immunity
after COVID infection.
Even the CDC does not
recommend measles vaccine
if you have measles immunity,
the same was true for smallpox,
but you ignore
history and science
to shame the flat
earthers, as you call them.
You should be ashamed of
yourself and apologize
to the American people
for being dishonest
about naturally-acquired
immunity.
You want more people
to choose vaccination,
so do I.
You wanna lessen vaccine
hesitancy, so do I.
You wanna have that happen?
Quit lying to people about
naturally-acquired immunity.
Quit lording it over people,
acting as if these people
are deplorable and unwashed,
try persuasion instead
of government cudgels,
try humility instead
of arrogance,
try freedom instead of coercion,
but most of all,
try understanding that there's
no more basic medical right
than deciding what we
inject into our bodies.
Today, after hearing
that millions of people
in a study prove,
show without a doubt,
that there's a great
deal of immunity
from getting it naturally,
do you want to apologize to
the a hundred million Americans
who suffered through COVID,
survived, have immunity,
and yet you wanna hold them
down and vaccinate them,
do you want to apologize
for calling those
people flat earthers?
- Senator, I appreciate
your question
and appreciate that
everyone has their opinion.
We follow the facts
and the science at HHS.
We use the expertise of
the medical professionals,
the scientists at HHS
to make decisions.
It's a team effort and we
rely on what is on the ground,
showing us results.
- Except for the dozens
and dozens of studies.
In fact, most, if not
all of the studies,
show robust immunity from
getting the disease naturally.
The CDC says if you've had
measles and have immunity,
you don't have to be vaccinated.
The same was true of smallpox.
You're selectively doing this
because you want us to submit
to your will.
You have no scientific
background, no
scientific degrees.
And yet, you aren't
really concerned
about a hundred million
Americans who had the disease.
You just wanna tell
us, do as you're told.
That's what you're telling us.
You want to mandate
this on all of us.
You're gonna tell us if I
have a hundred employees,
you're willing to put
me out of business
with a $700,000
fine
if I don't obey what you
think is the science.
Don't you understand
that it's presumptuous
for you to be in charge
of all the science?
Have you ever heard
of a second opinion?
I can't go to my doctor and
ask my doctor's opinion?
I mean, this is incredibly
arrogant combined
with this authoritarian
nature that you think,
well, we'll just tell all
of America to do what I say
and they better or we'll
fine them or put them in jail
or not let them go to school
or not let them travel.
The science is
against you on this.
The science is clear.
Naturally-acquired immunity
is as good as a vaccine.
The Israel study actually
showing it better.
This isn't an argument
against the vaccine,
but it's an argument for
letting people make a decision
who already have immunity.
- You seem pretty calm
and measured there.
Do you think any of this
gets through to these people?
- Well, you know, the arrogance,
he came to my home state
and proudly proclaimed
that anybody who
didn't agree with him
on vaccine policy
was a flat earther.
And frankly, I think
they're the flat earthers.
They're the ones not paying
attention to science.
In fact, if you are directing
science for the country
or directing policy in
that area for the science,
and you say that
science has settled,
you're clearly not a scientist
because the science is
never settled in any field.
In fact, that's how
we get to the truth.
Scientists, like everybody,
else argue back and forth,
you know, on the data.
They produce another
experiment specifically
to disprove another scientist
or to prove their point
and then other scientists
come back and forth
and the truth is
determined by that process
of argumentation.
It used to be the journalism
was somewhat that way too,
that we argued back and forth.
But now there's no
real argumentation
because if you state an opinion
that someone disagrees with
on the left,
they don't want your
opinion to be heard.
They want you to be nullified
and sent into a dark corner
and never seen again.
And that's the
opposite of people who
actually are skeptical
and wanna find the truth.
- So when you talk to them
about monoclonal antibodies
or that you've had COVID,
whatever it might be
and we see these hearings
and they just, sort
of, don't respond
or there's just no, oh, we
should look into that further,
is anything happening
after the hearings other
than a nice viral moment?
I mean, is anyone
looking again at the data
and going boy, you know,
it is, a year and a half
after two weeks to
flatten the curve,
maybe we did do
something wrong here?
- People are watching at home
the same way people are
watching your podcast now.
They're not watching
the nightly news on CNN,
but I'll give you an example.
I called up a supporter
in Tennessee today
and he says he
has 175 employees.
He said after he heard
about what I was saying
on the monoclonal antibodies,
they have a weekly meeting
with their employees
where they talk to them
about health strategies.
They talked about
monoclonal antibodies
and what it takes to be an
advocate for your family
to get treatment.
One of a, a prominent
Republican in Kentucky,
I talked to him six months ago
and told him about
monoclonal antibodies.
He's been fully vaccinated.
He got COVID, was
getting sicker.
No one was offering it to him.
I intervened and helped him
to get the monoclonal
antibodies,
not with one phone call
with three phone calls,
because there was
such resistance
from various parties on this.
And it took the followup
to get that done.
Not enough people know
that there is a treatment.
Look, this is beyond
the debate on vaccinated
or unvaccinated.
- [Dave] Uh-huh.
- Both groups can get
sick and are getting sick,
but the idea that the
government would own all
of this medicine, the
monoclonal antibodies,
and be in charge
of distributing it,
we've accepted
Chinese socialism.
We may have gotten
the virus from 'em.
Now, we're accepting
Chinese socialism
in the distribution of
the potential remedy
and it's not working very well.
- So I mean, is that really
what this is all about?
That they are leading
us to vaccine mandates,
not even because this
is really about COVID,
but this is the
beginning of some sort
of social credit system
where, yes, you're
a good citizen
because you got the
vaccine mandate,
oh, and you're
also a good citizen
cause you didn't speak
out about the government,
et cetera, et cetera?
Is that really where
we're headed with this?
- Yeah, and even if you
imagine that there is a role
for government, doctors, public
health people prescribing
what we should do or giving us,
they're giving the wrong advice.
So if you're 85 years old,
your chance of dying from
COVID is 10,000 times greater
than a ten-year-old.
So should we be mandating
vaccines on ten-year-olds
or suggesting to 85-year-olds
that either a booster
or a potential new Delta
variant vaccine might be good
for you?
That's a debatable point.
If you're 85 years old,
- [Dave] Uh-huh.
- I would listen to
what they're saying,
but if you're 10 years old,
it's not a good advice.
So, like, in the United Kingdom,
they're not pushing the
vaccine on children.
They're actually taking
the vaccine they have
and extending it as a possible
booster for those who are
at risk over age 65.
So that's what sane
people would be doing.
Instead, Fauci tells you, no,
we don't have enough
people vaccinated,
so we have to force it
on the children who are,
by and large, not
affected by this disease.
- So last I saw, the CDC
numbers, I'm not making it up.
People can fact check me.
CDC that, said that under 18,
.002%
of children will die of COVID,
not 2%, .002,
yet, here I am in crazy Cali
where Newsom has now just said,
in effect, that all
children five and up,
they're gonna start
with 12 and up,
but they're going to try to
get it down to five and up,
have to be vaccinated.
What would you do if
you were a citizen
in California right now?
If you were just someone
trying to keep their job,
make sure that they could
get their kid to school,
what would you do?
- Move, move immediately.
Leave communist
California and get away.
It is a beautiful state.
I love visiting.
I mean, it would be a great
place to live if it weren't
for your government.
But it's hard.
Some people can't afford
to move, but then again,
some people can't afford
to live there either
because of the taxes
and the property taxes
and everything else have
ginned up property so much.
There isn't a great
advice for people
who can't afford to move.
If you can afford to move,
they're great places.
I think even if you're a
person of ordinary means,
let's say you make
40 or $50,000 a year,
which I think is a
person of ordinary means,
think how much further your
money would go in Texas,
where they don't
take taxes out of it,
where property is less
and apartments are less.
That's why people are moving
by the tens of thousands,
Texas and Florida have
no state income tax.
So there's a great deal of
mass migration going on.
But the bottom line is people
are gonna have to decide
whether they want
freedom or coercion.
And in California, they're
choosing Democrats,
but the Democrats are going
to tell you what to do
in your economic life,
but now they're willing
to tell you what to do
in your personal, medical
decisions as well.
I can't imagine wanting to
live under that kind of rule.
- How worried are
you that eventually
as we split more and more,
and I sense that is
where this is going
and good people are
just gonna leave.
You know, if you
care about freedom,
you're just gonna
leave these states.
How worried are you that
in a place like Kentucky
or some of the other places
you mentioned Texas, Florida,
that eventually the
federal system will still
just keep encroaching
on them and just say,
oh, we don't care
about states' rights
because clearly they don't
care about any of our norms,
first amendment, fourth
amendment, et cetera.
- It is a big concern because
we're federalizing all
of this.
And now that you have
Biden Administration,
many of the folks from
California with bad ideas,
like Bassera, are
from California,
are now in the administration.
So yeah, we don't want
California bringing their policy
to Washington, DC, nor do
we want them in Kentucky.
And this is a real problem,
but it's a big battle.
And it's really a battle
between collectivism
and individualism.
People need to realize
that the collectivist think
that you are too stupid
to make your own decisions
so experts in each field
need to make these decisions
for you and that your
individual rights don't matter.
And the classic example
of this is Dr. Fauci.
In 2012, he said
that, yes,
this gain of function
is great research,
and we need to do it.
We might get a leak and there
could even be a scientist
who starts a pandemic,
but it'd be worth it.
The only way it's worth it is
if you discount 4 million
individual lives that have died.
If this came from
the lab in Wuhan,
which a lot of evidence
points towards it coming
from that lab, 4 million,
maybe I think it's closer
to 5 million, we're approaching
5 million people have died
from this,
but if you're a collectivist,
you'd think, well the
greater good of research
that is accumulated from
this in my estimable opinion,
because my opinion is so much
better than everybody else,
that I'm a scientist that's
the expert at the top,
I think really the
research is more important
than the individual deaths,
but that he's judging
the collective
to be more important
than the individual.
And that's what it leads to.
That's why Mao would say,
what is 45 million deaths,
you know, from famine
when the greater good
of socialism has come about?
This is what socialism
and collectivism breeds.
- Is that worship of the
expert class also, sort of,
the way they've figured
out a perfect system here.
Meaning when, when the
numbers go down, they say,
oh, it's because we've
still got everybody in masks
and we've still
kept people at home
and they're
vaccinated, et cetera,
et cetera.
But then when numbers
go up, they go,
oh, it's just because not enough
people are listening to us.
So they've created
this perfect system
where no matter how much logic
and reason you drop right now,
that you're still the bad guy.
- There's a lot
of studies looking
at the correlation
between mandates
and the incidence
of the disease.
It turns out that they are
not proportional at all.
There is no evidence that
when a mandate is instituted,
either a mask or stay
six feet away from people
or wear garlic around your neck,
any of these things
that they ask you to do,
they don't seem to have any
correlation with a reduction
in incidence.
In fact, as the
mandates were coming on,
in some cases, like
in last January,
the incidence was still
going through the roof.
Now, a month later,
after millions of
people are killed off,
the curve comes down,
but in all likelihood, it
has more to do with immunity.
But if you wanna see the true
dishonesty of these people,
look at the interview on CNN
where Dr. Fauci's
finally asked a question
about natural immunity.
He looks at the camera,
he looks at the interviewer
and he says, well, gosh,
that, you're right.
That should be something
we might want to look into.
Really?
The nation's leading expert
on infectious disease
and immunology thinks that
after a year and a half
and 4 million people dying,
we might want to look at that.
He knows very well the answer.
You put him on a
lie detector test
and you ask him, is
there naturally cloud,
acquired immunity from COVID?
He'll absolutely tell you yes.
He's actually said
it in interviews.
- [Dave] Uh-huh
- He wants to deemphasize it
because he thinks the
collective will do better
if they just blindly
accept the vaccine.
If you ask him,
is there a chance there
might be more side-effects
if you've already had COVID
and you're a 15-year-old male,
is there maybe more of an
incidence of myocarditis?
His real answer
is he doesn't care
about one 15-year-old male.
He cares about all
15-year-old male.
So he cares about
the collective.
He doesn't care about your kid,
which is not what
most parents want
when they go to the
doctor, a doctor who says,
well, most 15 year
olds'll be fine.
Yours might die, but you know,
what's one kid when we give,
when we save the rest of them?
- Right, and we're
also hearing all sorts
of stuff from the CDC.
Walensky the other day was
saying this thing about,
you know, women who were
pregnant should get the vaccine
and they, and don't
worry about breastfeeding
or any of these things.
The implication being,
oh, we've studied this
for a couple of years
and it'll be okay,
but that's simply impossible
at this point, right?
- I think that giving out
advice is not a bad idea.
So I have a sister
who's an OBGYN,
and she did tell me that
they have a 29-year-old,
pregnant mom in their hospital
who died just
recently with COVID.
So we shouldn't say
that it can't happen
and the judgment should
be the individual
and they have to do it.
So, for example,
you'll meet young moms
in the first trimester
who won't drink a diet Coke,
cause they are worried
about the development
of their child in the
first three months.
That might be rational
or irrational,
but it's their child
and their choice.
It might be the same
way with the vaccine.
They might weigh that
decision and they might say,
well, I might do it in
the second trimester.
I might do it in
the third trimester.
Or they might say,
for either religious
reasons or medical reasons,
that I don't want to.
In a free society, each
individual makes their decision.
So I wouldn't tell people
not to get vaccinated
or to be so afraid of it
that if you're pregnant,
not to do it.
There are some unknowns.
I would say, investigate it,
listen to your doctor,
talk to your doctor,
read about the fact that
some pregnant women have died
in their 30s and in their 20s.
But by, the thing is,
is
in a free society,
no one individual
makes these decisions
and it's never right for
one individual to make it
because what if that
individual's wrong?
That means 330 million people,
when Fauci is wrong,
330 million people
are subject to that.
If your local doctor is
wrong, get another doctor,
get another opinion, try to
figure out the truth of this,
but we're going in the
wrong direction so rapidly.
The question is,
will we ever get our freedoms
back after this is all done?
- Yeah, it's just
so extraordinary.
I mean, the basic idea
of the United States
is the individual rights.
And as you're saying, it's like,
we're just throwing 'em out.
So let's spend
the remaining time
doing some basic math here,
because I've been told
over the last a week,
time and time again by the
president of the United States
and many of the people
in his administration,
that $3.5 trillion
actually equals zero.
- Hm.
- I tried to put it
on my calculator.
It doesn't have enough digits.
Can you help me with that math?
- I think most people
are smart enough to say
that there's nothing
in life that's free.
This is a bait and switch.
This is the Democrat saying,
you're going to
get free college.
You're going to
get free daycare.
You're going to get
a free cell phone.
Heck, we might even
throw in a free car.
You know, there's going
to be a lot of free stuff,
but people know innately,
they know that that's not true.
So when, when Biden says that
it's not gonna cost anything,
one of the ways they do
the trickery of the math
to try to make it seem as
if it's not costing anything
or costing that much is
they're going to say,
oh, the bill will only include
two years of free college.
And does that mean that
at the end of two years,
there's no more free college?
No, at the end of the two years,
the only way you get
free college is everybody
in Congress would
have to get together
and get rid of free college.
Well, it's hard to
get rid of free stuff.
Once people get free stuff,
- [Dave] Yeah.
- they think they like it.
But in the end, we're all
going to pay for this,
either through more
taxation or more inflation.
And what happens
through inflation is
it's an insidious tax
and it affects the working class
and the retired, pension
folks that have fixed incomes,
more than the rest of us.
And it's why a decade later,
if you make $35,000 a
year and a decade later,
you make $38,000 a
year and you're like,
how come I'm not any richer?
- [Dave] Mm-hm.
- It's because
now your $38,000
buys $33,000 worth
of goods because of inflation.
And so, this is the real trick,
but it's a bait and switch
and it's an intentional thing.
The Democrats are wanting to
buy your vote with free stuff.
They give you free stuff,
but they don't tell
you the honest truth
that your money will
buy less each year,
and that in the end,
you won't be any better off.
- What do you think Biden
believes in his heart of hearts?
I mean, I can't imagine
that he actually thinks
that taxing $3.5
trillion of the bad guys
that he keeps saying
don't pay their fair share
is actually nothing
and it won't add to the debt
and it won't cause inflation
and everything else.
But you think it's just like,
the train has just gone here
and he's just going
in on all of it?
- You know, I think the big
syndrome among most Democrats,
if you wanna give them the
benefit of the doubt is
that they are big
heart, small brain.
And so, they think
with their heart
and they just wanna help people,
don't you just
wanna help people?
But they don't think through
the consequences of this.
It's sort of like unemployment.
We just wanna help people,
so why don't we double
the unemployment?
But what it does is it
leads to people staying out
of work longer.
And in the end,
when they decide to go
back in the workforce,
people are like,
well, you've only been
out of work 10 weeks,
but you've been out
of work a whole year
because the benefits were good.
You know what, I'd rather
have the guy's only been out
of work 10 weeks.
He seems hungrier to me.
And so, you create
a whole class,
an underclass of people
who are unemployable
and no longer part
of the workforce
and that wasn't good for them.
Work is good for the
soul, good for the art.
I mean, it's good
for the person.
And once you get them
out of the workforce,
you've done a disservice
to that, to them.
And you make them
sort of a dependent
on the democratic largesse.
And then they become
a solid Democrat voter
because they no longer
work or pay taxes.
We've developed a society
of workers and non-workers.
Most of the workers are
voting for less government
and less taxes.
Most of the non-workers
are, if they vote,
are voting for more
government and more welfare.
- So what do we do about
this debt ceiling situation?
I mean, basically, everyone
watching this knows
if you got a $2,000
limit on your credit card
and you hit it,
- Mm.
- your next purchase
isn't gonna go through.
You can't just tell the
bank, oh, no, no, no.
Now I want five, now I want 10.
Now I want 20, but that's
how the government operates.
- Democrats wanna
bust the budget with
these enormous bills.
They need to vote to
raise the debt ceiling.
It can be done.
They can do it
through the same way
they're gonna raise
the spending and taxes
on us through budget
reconciliation.
They can raise the debt ceiling.
But here's the thing.
There's all this
sturm and drang about,
oh, no, what are we gonna do?
The debt ceiling.
We bring in,
probably, I don't know,
we bring in about $3.8 trillion,
over a hundred billion
dollars a month,
a couple hundred
billion dollars a month,
we bring in.
The interest payment's
$300 billion a year.
So, you know, we
got plenty of money.
I mean, you bring
in 3.8 trillion
and the interest
payment's 300 billion,
how come we can't
pay the interest?
So there's no reason
to ever default.
All you'd have to do
is prioritize your
interest payments.
Now, it would mean you
might have to cut some waste
and you might have to cut
some spending in government.
But if we needed to,
in the next year,
we could actually balance
our budget in the next year.
And what we would do is
we would spend the money
on interest and we'd
probably spend the money
on social security and we
on Medicare.
And then a lot of the
crap, like, you know,
watching a lizard on a
treadmill might go out,
watching Japanese
quail snort cocaine,
that might go out,
studying Panamanian frogs,
- Well, let's keep that one.
- to see if the country
frogs are, you know,
have a better call to get
mates than the city frogs have.
I mean, you might cut
some of the crap out
that government spends money
on, which we need to do anyway.
And we never do it.
But now, there's, the
whole thing's a charade.
The, you know, the debt ceiling,
they will eventually raise it.
They can do it on their own,
but they wanna share the blame.
They want us to share the
blame for the debt bomb
that's working its
way into our system.
And I want no part of it.
I'm not voting to
raise the debt ceiling
cause I'm not voting
for the spending.
- Man, I should be
living in Kentucky.
I know you're
crunched on time here,
so I got one more for you,
which is that a whole
bunch of my audience,
and I would include
myself in this,
we're having trouble seeing
the silver lining right now
that star in the distance,
vaccine mandates, people
losing their job, inflation,
just the endless
lies from the media,
big tech censoring people,
like the whole thing.
And you know, the California
recall went horribly.
So, you know, I've been
depressed about that.
Like, what, do you see a
star in the distance here?
Do you see something sort
of tangible more than
just human spirit?
That's what I've been
trying to give people.
- Well, I would say
rather than looking
for a silver lining or saying
we have something good coming,
if we do nothing, we've
got the Gulag coming.
So if you don't want
the Gulag, fight back.
But I will say this.
If you want a note of optimism,
capitalism is
incredibly resilient.
Look at the wealth around you,
travel our country and see
such extraordinary wealth.
Not a few people,
thousands upon thousands
of people doing well.
People, look in my town,
I have people that
came from Bosnia,
you know, 10 years ago,
and that are some of the most
successful people in my town.
One gentleman, I know
owns four restaurants.
You bust your ass
to run a restaurant.
He's worked hard.
He's earned his way in America
and he's a great American now.
That's happening,
still happening,
despite how big government is
and despite the obstacles
and despite the
threat of socialism,
capitalism is
amazingly resilient.
We're doing amazingly well.
There's less poverty in
the world than at any time
in world history.
When you measure poverty
as extreme poverty,
less than $2 a day,
less than 10% of the people
live in extreme poverty now.
In 1820,
almost everybody in the world
lived in extreme poverty.
So we've come a long way,
but we need to remind
people we're here
and we made this incredible
success because of capitalism.
- Senator Rand Paul,
I thank you for taking the time
and I thank you for
fighting the good fight
in a place that
it's not too common.
- Thank you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist,
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.